we're going to continue our special
series kindness 101 with steve hartman
who's been sharing stories that are
built around themes of kindness and
character and the people who have
mastered those qualities today's lesson
ladies and gentlemen is service steve
and his kids show us how one girl's
commitment to her community lifted her
up as well
good morning this is my daughter meryl
hi and today we're talking about the joy
of doing hard work for no pay otherwise
known as service and as always we begin
by tossing over to your brother emmett
at the dictionary desk emmett good
morning everyone service is basically
the act of helping for no pay at all and
with the goodness of your heart right on
the one hand it kind of seems like a
burden yeah it kind of does yeah yet
about 25 of americans do some form of
volunteering and to understand why we
turn once more to our library of amazing
americans and pull off the shelf the
perfect person to show us the rewards of
service
at a nursing home in northwest arkansas
we found a gem named ruby
eleven-year-old ruby chitsy likes to go
to work with her mom amanda is a nurse
who travels to several nursing homes in
the area and it was on one of those
visits that ruby started going up to
residence with her notepad
if you could have any three things any
three things what would they be what
would you want she came up with this
idea of these questions yes with the
intention of what i don't think she had
an intention really ruby says she was
mostly just curious what they'd say were
you surprised i thought people would say
like money
houses
lamborghini
but instead here's what she got
electric razor new shoes vienna sausage
for some reason a lot of people asked
for vienna sausage and other really
basic items like that's all they wanted
and i really decided i needed to do
something
so she started a charity called three
wishes for ruby's residence i'm gonna
sit right beside you now while her mom
is caring for patients cheese ruby goes
room to room i love cheese i do too jots
down wishes avocados and then sets out
to grant those wishes thank you
sweetheart you're welcome ruby has a
gofundme to cover costs but again no one
is asking for a sports car here her
expenses are minimal especially compared
to the rewards
it really lifts you it really does
on this day she came back with a
wheelchair full of sausages and other
grocery items you have this huge
chocolate pie that you can eat all by
yourself but make no mistake this isn't
about food watermelon and oranges no one
has this kind of reaction over fresh
fruit alone
thank you so much
i can't believe it
whether she knows it or not ruby is
satisfying some much more basic human
needs here
to be remembered
to be cherished especially by a child
that is what our seniors are truly
hungry for and that is what ruby brings
every time she sets foot in a nursing
home
who needs a lamborghini you know i'm a
hugger when you've got home delivery
of all the happy you could handle
after i first shared that story ruby
expanded she now has kid helpers across
the country who have granted 25 000
wishes and counting that's a lot of
wishes and now she's granting our wish
by joining us hello ruby hi steve
helping people lifts you in what way
you know i used to struggle with really
bad mental health but ever since i've
started community surface i think this
really benefits me uh how many cans of
vienna sausage have you bought
gosh we give it to them so much that
they've like almost outgrown it so so
people have burned out on vienna sausage
at this point
what do you think you're gonna do next
in your life
i think i'm gonna continue what i'm
doing for a long time helping the
nursing home residents
they're just awesome to be around and
they're my best friends
we clone you
well i'm working on a clone right here
this is going to be my clone
oh my goodness that's awesome ruby
thanks so much for joining us appreciate
it i i really had a great time she
really does make it seem like
volunteering is worth a try for sure in
fact i think emmett could start out by
volunteering to clean your bedroom
yeah
i do get the idea of service just
cleaning meryl's bedroom is on a whole
different level all right well maybe you
can start by cleaning your home
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
i guess but that's a whole nother level
that's a whole nother level siblings
that's a perfect 10 all the way around
this 101 ruby the family that was
awesome yeah
on many different levels oh so good
steve always gives us steve always gives
us a lesson and we thank you for that
steve thank you so much